c'est une grande première dans la
commune dégremont la ville a inauguré ce
jeudi 8 juillet une borne électrique
le dispositif a été lancé en partenariat
avec les collectivités locales et
notamment seine et yvelines numériques
il permettra à deux véhicules de se
recharger en simultané en deux heures
c'est bien sûr destiné aux autres
montois qui n'ont pas si vous voulez des
bornes ou en tout cas un jardin
suffisamment grand pour avoir des bornes
pour recharger les véhicules
c'est pour des habitants c'est pour des
visiteurs c'est pour aussi toute une
série de personnes qui parlent sur la
rd30 sur la nationale 113 et qui ont
besoin de recharger leurs véhicules et
qu'ils feront un petit détour une petite
boucle pour venir le faire un projet
soutenu par la plupart des 1100
habitants de la commune
personnellement je suis très content de
cette installation parce que j'ai avec
j'ai acheté ma voiture il ya deux
semaines et justement je me posais la
question de west que je vais pour la
charger sur la commune et là ça répond
totalement à mes attentes
la ville de bromont n'est pas la seule
concernée par le projet seine et
yvelines numériques va également
installer des bornes dans six autres
commune yvelinoise cet été objectif
booster ce secteur il ya trois freins
finalement à l'acquisition de véhicules
électriques
1 le prix des véhicules électriques et
ça nous collectivités locales on n'y
peut rien de l'autonomie des véhicules
encore une fois on n'y peut pas
grand-chose et trois le nombre de points
de recharge et là c'est là qu'on a nous
collectivités locales un rôle à jouer
pour faciliter et faire tomber cette
barrière du nombre de points de recharge
si le projet concluant sur ces communes
l'objectif sera de proposer dès 2022 des
offres pour accompagner le développement
de l'électromobilité dans l'ensemble des
yvelines